following the uncertainty caused by
brexit EU citizens living in the UK need
information regarding their rights and
vest status in the country over the
coming years the government has already
introduced a new immigration status for
so-called settled status for EU
nationals already living and working in
the country which consists of a
mandatory registration process now if
you as an EU citizen living in the UK
have questions about brexit or indeed
the new registration process then you
can attend the EU citizens rights
session in strapper - on the 18th of
February the event hosted by
stratford-on-avon district council will
aim to answer your questions provide
advice and hopefully ease some of your
concerns regarding brexit and organising
the events are the three million a
non-for-profit organization which
campaigns to protect the rights of EU
citizens post brexit the session takes
place in the council chamber within
Elizabeth house on Church Street
stratford-upon-avon between 6 p.m. and 8
p.m. and is completely free to any who
wish to attend to register your interest
now head over to Eventbrite co-taught UK
and we look forward to seeing you there
you